there's a little cap on the bottle you
see the you see the little bottle here
this has a purpose right this little
plastic on the table has a purpose the
keys in my pocket have a purpose so I'm
making guys how you doing miss Amelia
hamdullah how's it going continuing our
tour in Bosnia meeting some wonderful
people and we got a scholar in the area
here so we were having a nice
conversation and I can't leave you guys
out of the conversation so I'm gonna ask
some questions at the same time go ahead
and let me practice my Bosnian so excuse
me and we'll have a translator so I was
asking the [ __ ] you know how does he get
people to reflect right you know before
we get into religion and whatnot about
their purpose in life everything around
us has a purpose
there's a little cap on the bottle you
see the you see the little bottle here
this has a purpose right this little
plastic on the table has a purpose the
keys in my pocket have a purpose how
does he get people to reflect here in
this area about you know to think to
ponder about this very important
question
Motum on up immunity but who thought I
told me hoody is that she Ludacris avid
avid - mission artisan starless Milani
accent not to that almost not ludecke
way positive ammonia is Ludacris a
survey told it assumes demand cars miss
from tsunami volume post a Nicholas
Sarah - Sarah Ali communism we email
glom it see the load may is not severe
is Islam news nanny suit it's not the
salute only code are you worried in
astonished Oh Jerry Messner that means
that she clawed me accent Nasheed of
inertia mission Ursa yes to t load first
point that she wanted to convey is that
here in Bosnia specific situation up
like we do in u.s. here we have most of
the people that confer that they are
Muslims and that they're practicing
Islam but actually they realize they
don't pray they don't practice the
foundation Salam so the first thing here
is to try to understand that shape and
dice here in Bosnia have different set
up of people for their inviting people
doing Dowa to people who already say
they're Muslims but they don't practice
their religion something beautiful
tell us all the experience now that he's
had as he
any live stories of people cuz we know
Islam is for everybody
doesn't matter it's not just restricted
to the Bosnian Muslims you know it's for
everyone so are there are examples of
creations accepting Islam
Serbians accepting Islam are there some
life stories he hasn't practical I
thinks he can share with us miss
McCauley the most efficacy role
prevention on Caterpie time you seen our
story tava
non-muslim on e e concept nursery Davi
missing our street a cop concealed
okunoshima the pita in her basket of it
and Serbian ago renewed resume as
opposed to Isaac is the ludus Lucia
Uno's to me over emo yacon neoprene la
noche no knew him standard dima de
kirchner SUV van is llama
EEMA loot equip Riveter islamic releases
la mo cuishle mo contact him a putin
email you telephones cameras Garima
origanum silmas Nishida Lucido goddesses
na mo the sucking dominum slavish alicia
ludus interest with islam is very shy lu
d Perrotti
rod miss you Naraku Bosnia Sunni Imam
militias Luciano pottery studio lazuli
at ruthless nama kuku mathur olive Islam
connects out to what he said previously
that most of the Muslims here don't
practice wrong and the Dawa is focused
on them but however even the focus of
Dawa and the concept is made for already
Muslims in our neighborhood close
neighborhood here we have Serbians and
Croatians who are Christians different
denominations of Christianity but
they're both Christians and we had many
cases of them through following YouTube
and Facebook and social media they they
converted to Islam but in this most of
these cases there were many cases most
of them they would convert on the on
their own while their home watching our
die is watching their do Dawa to Muslims
for not practicing Islam non-muslims
wouldn't ourselves so this is
interesting and this is just showing us
how powerful is this message of Islam
and the truth there's not amazing sure
they're basically self educating they're
at home listening to people like him you
know they're inquisitive they want to
know and then there's
said earlier that when they would come
and say okay I converted to some say
already here he would be surprised how
much these people knew about Islam but
much more than most of the Muslims here
in in Bosnia because they've been
addicted is LOM for already some period
for maybe one two years then they
learned so much so they're already
strong Muslims at the point where they
convert isn't that amazing we have so
many examples like that of people
watching the program calling the number
1 800 662
let me ask you a couple more questions
before we cut out we know that you guys
by now who've been watching it some
tuning in for the first time Islam is
based on five pillars five okay one two
three four five one is that you
testified that there's nothing worthy of
worship except the creator of the
heavens in the earth and Mohammed is the
last and final messenger in the line of
messengers preceding him Jesus Moses
Abraham excited list ozone they all came
with the same message
now you gotta prove that you believe by
the actions one of those is pray or five
times a day so the bush knock right this
is the specialty here you know the
Muslims who are born Muslims and now
they're not praying what does he do to
help motivate people to fault his hedge
dad you know somebody call which is
actually more snow midsi yeah cuz I do
the posi with shampoo shine the
innovativeness Michelin meaning I beat
[ __ ] it's to pump like an easter egg
named easily cola technique we won't
read yeah no stop no to Iman Casa Toby
China today
don't be Louisa post a Venus Tomoko
that's true hypnotist sunny many Bittman
some other the author him he'd like a
pozzolan are as mission Annie
Yellowstone on a big rock we met hood
naked choke as a stress to Gehenna
Monica choucas Anika to deposit II and
the Goguryeo already put imagine a
Taneycomo cavora t colloquy posit it is
lost a body Tanika to have put it sat in
an mm install in your day Erasmo rosna
me to the core esteem us and what I will
do then is vocally is call attention
across - wobba either we put your as
mission when you speak up to Akashi yes
and put your admission to is a menu spec
Shea gives us example that the problem
here with most of the people is that
they attacked in their everyday life
they're like zombies for the other
hypnotized because everyday life is so
fair
and they basically don't think much or
that don't think at all about the
everyday life so his first step is to
try to make them ponder about their life
so he gave few examples maybe he would
try to he would talk about Jahannam
about the Hellfire and then tried to
scare him in a way to think about their
life but then he would talk about Jenna
about the heaven about beauties of
heaven or talk about beauty of being a
worshipper of one God of how how good is
this experience or just talk about
creation to make people wonder how are
they created why are they here so any
any way of talking doing Dawa to people
just to make them think so he says when
when somebody tells him I started
thinking that for him this is success
what message does he have for those
Bosnians they left Bosnia they're living
in America maybe he wants to give us
alarm and a message to them and how can
they if they want to learn more from him
maybe he has some lectures how can they
find his materials but my opposing team
no Samia is Kushan team problem Tomoko
do go preach at emogo do go preach at
the soccer coach Matt and Dana dobra
star the solute daveggio
a kovitch resume new boss and squeezing
the servicio as i ludic will go very
nasty music aam aadmi his fukaku natural
she suffered cool stuff just I was ovum
I am a linguist already in position
Facebook profile now you to women more
at Taman aqui widow Issa Shaka and
economist emoji in son it would see that
mojo notion Stoker is no a variant a
merits a dynamo jihad nikasha so much
email witness me a tip or taught cigano
Yellin what Matilda was even a dude
yesterday Milan ekkada Iridessa limo
nests MIMO we are in Villa Kapooka
yesterday in Sun this min occurs above
80 divided we are all as an Mis movie
story need a logic Shinobu Java mo in
sand trip a set to poaching tatami pezzo
di do to America Australia who was new
mesme matasaburo team is most foreign
delegation Abu Jaffa mo certain Arab
opportunity
Tony insanity was
sir this way Korean native as well in
Sweden today to travel jollity Road
means Keveza three brothers now Oh doc
aah time
Takako Santos pituitary rowdy at Tony
inshallah mr. O'Shay ally epochs a
instant miss mr. Perrotti in a sweet and
heated quest I owe that clear photos to
Nash identity do beaucoup beaucoup
service we the Islam tokuda identity
Bosnia Kai identity Islam ski me Momoko
Liana misma out of Tony not everywhere
ski outfit Islam ski tokuda Nachi peruca
nesting was a private cosmic Cosmo miss
mimosa variety the story need a lodge or
genre memo oniy quiz night wasn't
classic Rico Sam makuta nastily
practically national Putin Facebook
mogoon austerity put'em YouTube canal
Allah as a chi dost a tube material
ah-kuei mobility one of his skills one
of his characteristics that he can speak
a lot hamdullah so he proved it to
invest near now basically he also humbly
proposed that there is a - a - a fat
couch which he would also propose
besides him for our Muslim brothers and
sisters in u.s. or all over the world so
basically the shakes a fat couch and she
have a dim page which they have there on
all social medias and you can find many
of their video clips or cereals about
different topics on Islam so definitely
it's one option to educate yourself more
on Islam in your own language if your
Bosnia so that's the first thing second
thing that she said about advice you
asked him to give advice for brothers
and sisters that live in u.s. or all
over the world the first advice from him
is to never forget why do you live on
this earth no matter where do you go if
you want to us for work for family or
any other reason the main goal of your
life is to worship one God so never
forget this wherever you are and second
thing that she said me I forgot
State v organism what i've ii ii ii ii
thing very important not to forget is
your identity so even if you left your
country you should always maintain as
you're doing now you're learning again
even if you're born ears you're learning
your language here in bosnia you're
learning the history of your country and
our country humbler has very rich
history very rich history of islam and
we are one of the only where we are the
only people are left here in europe as a
regional nation of muslims so there's a
lot of things that connect our Bosnians
to islam and tall rich heritage so this
another advice never forget away from
that's it guys this is raw this is first
this is unrehearsed unscripted letting
you guys in I just had one more thing
came to my mind real important this
won't take long
if someone's Serbian if someone because
someone things like they've mixed up you
know the ethnicity ethnicity right with
the religion so does someone if they
accept there's only one God worship Him
alone not as crazy Muhammad is the
messenger automatically I've included
Jesus Moses Abraham all the preceding
messengers you got it good you've been
self educating know that but now do they
stop being served do they stop being
Croatian do they have to be Bosnian now
or just Muslim how does that work he's
lovely managed a setting it's not she
took muchos 30 Australian as much a bit
American it's Muslim and a lodge or some
cash in a chronic mental law at Kaku
Allah sonically Sarah twister on kanji
kuransky right Joyce tasuku Allah
neighbor who asked you any quickest in a
v-shape way Allah who sonically sad some
caching reduce to MIDI so on I Coggan
Evo ideal a nice pass in a chicken egg
whopper it was past night with 0jt
version post Anika questioning so does
Molly
Epis Lonnie Collison booty poustinik a
zani ricotta tuition Jahannam taco de
Chubbuck accost Russia Boston ski Isaac
Cruz Boston's case Chivero own Nima Nika
crevasses sat in Dom Sutra Morabito boo
sonnets on mojo slit a hermit attraction
images that eat riba das tenemos a
sacrament Ypres kanji which non-genic a
pseudonym of a leprechaun 2-0 Boop
resume protagonist a week two prismatic
or actually corrosion
horoscope or a true meritocracy nostra
people mr. bean L chakra D mu zero a
gory
Vasudha mean identity toast a toast oh
yes teh aliens amo para kunoichi Posto
instance via stands dr. Savina to narc
Tokuda theists vari with lawmen aminika
cabeza choukaku primi Islam Chuck Nia
with neova
the topic obstinacy Islamic Maghreb AQIM
Sleeman Italy Khan is not a Muslim on
Unicode Allah Allah Tala
Oh peace and hope that could dynamic all
Muslim anima me a patron a Bruin was
Nina Putin listen ecopra peace tree nama
you know Stan Allah Achra Fe Dean we are
saluting only lewd eulogy movie rue is
Virginia that was from me put read me
Allah I put them smoothly so first thing
that she said that no matter where you
from from United States Australia Serbia
Croatia Islam has nothing to do with
your nationality and there's no national
in Islam
so Islam is clear from this and he also
gave us the one ayah from Quran and
hadith from our prophet muhammed
sallalahu lives and to prove this the
ayah from Quran says that the best in
front of God are the one there are most
conscious of God so this is one and the
second is hadith from the Prophet
Muhammad sallallaahu 7 which I'm going
to paraphrase that that only your deeds
will be accounted for on the Judgment
Day so these two parameters show us that
nationality has nothing to do with this
the only thing that is important that
you clear your heart that you connect
directly to God you can stay creation
you can stay serbian
any other nationality you don't have to
change your nationality and also she
says that you can even if it's hard for
you to portray or islam publicly you can
convey your islam privately and you can
be a muslim without other people knowing
because Allah so Allah is all-knowing
and all-seeing so he knows about your
son so important message that she wanted
to portray is that there is no
nationality in Islam and Islam is one
religion for people I'm the law we
learned a lot here and again this was
raw bringing it to you guys for my tour
in Bosnia continue to tune in we're
gonna bring you some wonderful stories
meeting some wonderful people
Thank You jazz up Lahaina Salam alaikum
to Allah peace be with you
[Music]